[ __ ] we did it no we did it read it we
did it
this is bit this is bigger than [ __ ]
the wall street bets thing in my opinion
sometimes we gotta sometimes we gotta
pat ourselves on the back and i think
this is one of those times
hey fellow youtubers i
got some great news guys
i made it to 1k
dustin tv aj stoner
jj luck he made it
and i love his skirt
i finally made it to 1k i
grind all these rising [ __ ]
grinding
videos going live going to people
rising grind that's what i'm talking
about dustin
rise and grind live streams
show us some love for them and also i'm
noticing the georgia bulldogs hat there
and most georgia fans wear skirts
is your love back i finally
made 1k
i managed to my goal as long as i have
1k
i'm fine
i am so happy
it wouldn't be possible why am i subbed
to a man in a skirt um
because you're an american i'm assuming
you're american because you're a hero
without my my fans
i am popular now
i am famous i am a youtube famous yes
yes he is he's youtube famous fellas
he's youtube famous fellas
now i can say i'm official youtuber
i know i've been a youtuber for a while
but i am
in the big leagues now yeah welcome
aboard everybody
welcome aboard huh
look we have another youtube famous guy
in the chat of donna's paul's here hey
how does it feel to have a new peer my
friend
how does it feel to have a new peer in
the youtube game huh
pretty good pretty good right
feels nice feels nice
road to a million folks we're doing it i
am 1k
now thank you
everybody to help me out
it went long it went a long way
to help me out yes it wouldn't be
possible
without y'all hey jade i have a question
for you
because you obviously been covering this
guy longer than me um
i know he likes to wear skirts but is he
is is he jj you were no better than me
is i'm just curious
i thank y'all for the bottom of my heart
thank you for helping a guy
who wears that's the million-follower
question so we don't know if he's gay
i just think he's come i just think he
wants to be comfortable
denim skirts on his youtube channel
and y'all showed me love y'all brought
me into your heart
you brought me into your home
you know not actually in your home yeah
i wouldn't let you in my house buddy i
mean i i hear you
but i wouldn't let you in my house you
know what i'm saying
you brought me into your heart you
brought me into your home
and you showed me love in you and you
helped me grow
and i do appreciate it i am in
i'm 1k now
1 k i cannot believe it i got to pinch
myself
i want to thank you look all i want is a
and look a double the let's
be fair here i want i want him to thank
me and i want him to thank jj stoner
i want a double shout out i want to
thank you for me and i thank you for
just that's all i want
i want nothing more than that you give
me that and i'm happy
i must be dreaming because
dustin tv the guy who wears skirts
on his channel with a 1k
that can't be possible oh it's possible
but let's guess what
it is i'm 1k guys
it's all because of you my viewers
my friends my family well let's let's
not let's not call each other friends
okay thomas is my friend
i'm still learning about you my youtube
family
it's all because of you
i wouldn't be here i wouldn't
be 1k without y'all
in the part of my heart thank you
hey y'all don't care for me y'all
brought me in
you're you probably you said you're one
of us
now thank you i don't
yeah you know what [ __ ] it you're one of
us now welcome
welcome
[ __ ] welcome
and i aboard every last one of you that
showed me love and supported my youtube
channel i do
for all these years and the new ones i
met a couple days ago
i hope everything goes good in your life
oh that's nice of him i hope god bless
y'all
oh thank you so good oh that's really
nice
you don't know how much
i am blessed to have you
he's talking to me folks you're helping
me out you're welcome
you know you got it bud you came into my
life all right you can stop now you said
hey you're over there let's get this guy
dustin tv to one game no i appreciate it
no i got it but we don't need anymore
thank you you're welcome but we're done
my friends are
all right stop no i got it you're
repeating yourself youtubers
thank you but enough like i said god
bless you
i mean no i get it hope people i guess i
appreciate it
but i don't we're good i we're good
okay no i bless you sir but we're fine
and i love every last time
you know
no no that's fine
cool well well i got to go so i'm gonna
okay okay just keep going keep
doing live streams y'all want to come up
my youtube i got a you're immortal oh i
get it
but i have a meter outside i got to put
a quarter in it so i got
calling you my little dustin's i can't
okay look
can we please not i feel like i'm gonna
call you don't don't call me now i'm
gonna start saying
hey fellow youtubers i don't and hey my
little dustin i don't like that i don't
like that i did not
this is not what i agreed with when i
subscribed please don't
okay i got it
welcome to the destination okay no i
apprec
just call me robert voice is fine just
viewers viewers is fine i gotta get out
of here
it wouldn't be possible no i get it i
got it
but i would be here i tested i would be
here right now this video okay i finally
hit 1k
okay okay okay thank you
okay i got it okay well cool but thanks
man i gotta
have a blessed night i'm gonna stay
i hope god is good y'all oh that's so
good i gotta go walking down the street
i hope you find it no i get it
that's how i much want god to be good to
y'all because y'all being
good to me y'all help me out with
1k so i appreciate it but i gotta go i
really gotta get okay
for the bottom of my heart if someone's
right it's like trying to leave a
[ __ ] weed dealer's house he doesn't
ever shut the [ __ ] up about it just
gotta go i gotta go five minutes later
hey fellow youtubers he's just i want
all my fellow youtubers to know
i am your
youtube universal
champion means i am the youtube
champion of all youtube
and i'm doing an open challenge
to anybody if a fellow youtuber
wants to step in the ring
okay all right you want a party bite
i made you and i'll end you i'll meet
you and i'll end you
you two universe oh is he cutting a
promo oh
ho ho
[Music]
anybody want some all you have to do
is come get some
all you have to do follow youtubers
you have to
leave a comment down below you want a
challenge
this is an open challenge
for the youtube universal
champion
guys
if anybody wants to
come after me for the youtube
universal championship anybody
oh boy getting cocky right off the bat
huh right now
it seems to me i
am the top youtube
star because i am
the youtube all right university all
right no that's fine
only way you can be a top youtuber
is beat me for the youtube
universal champion that's fine sure
anybody wants some
come get some
i'm doing an open challenge has
anybody wants an open challenge
for my youtube
universal championship
come on guys i'm doing an open challenge
for y'all
anybody wants to take
this away from me all you have to do is
show up
okay guys you know i'm just playing
no no no no no no no no no you don't get
to [ __ ] now after cutting that promo
you want to take on all challengers is
that what you want
is that what you want
well let me tell you something dustin
i've been in this game
longer than you have
i have gone through thousands of you
and you are just another step
in the [ __ ] ladder to success for
this guy
so i accept your challenge
cage match this sunday
at no way out i'm gonna grab you by your
ponytail
all right you braid wyatt wannabe
and i'm gonna rip your little skirt off
[Music]
you better hope you have your little
podunk police on speed dial
because i'm gonna smash your head
through that little trailer park
you live in and take that belt and take
all your skirts and i'm gonna leave you
there
crying naked and alone
i accept
[Music]
and unlike you i'm not playing
i want that belt
[Music]
just huh
[ __ ] think he is